côté madame à un brave garçon comme le
bol ça disparaît pas comme ça je
m'inquiétais pas mon fils il est pas
comme ça ce sont toutes ces histoires là
c'est pas lui ça lui ressemble pas c'est
tout dire même ses coups il n'en a pas
loupé il en loupe à aider comme ça
jusqu'à nouvel avis je vais donner des
cours particuliers de france elle a
l'air en tant que professeur devine pas
mal de choses sans qu'il y ait
véritablement de saint flour pays s'est
confié à vous sa famille est à peine
elle étouffe
je sais pas pourquoi ce monsieur qui ça
peut-être que c'est lui qui provoque ces
humeurs chez mon fils et si on fait
cette battue vous pensez qu'on peut
retrouver son cadavre dans cette forêt
pourquoi vous étiez des formules
cadavres dans cette forêt jusqu'à preuve
du contraire on est là pour trouver des
traces seulement
au risque de laisser court alors il a
une pièce à lui quelque chose
la plupart du temps là sur la table ou
sinon parfois dans la cave en cave
on a négligé quelque chose depuis le
début de cette enquête on a cru la mer
pourquoi tu veux absolument de cette
femme aimante elle prive entendant la
gueule là
ouais
[Musique]
vous parlez de ben ali ou pas je
cherchais coin devant toutes ces choses
sur jan
je vais me lever et partir si acier
par des droits dont nous ne tenait pas
compte
[Musique]
vous avez trouvé plus fort que mon
commandant